non bonjour à tous merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne
une audition dont les membres de la
commission d' enquête sur l'efficacité
de la lutte contre le dopage se
souviendront longtemps
il s'agit en effet de l'audition de
travis tygart tu le président de
l'agencé antidopage américaine
lagence de lutte contre le dopage la
plus efficace au monde c'est elle qui a
fait tomber à la star mondiale du
cycliste lance armstrong entraînant le
retrait de ses sept titres de vainqueur
de tour de france et ses aveux sur
médiatisées quelques mois après devant
les sénateurs
travis tygart a donné une véritable
leçon de lutte contre le dopage mais il
a surtout jeté un pavé dans la mare
estimant qu'il fallait réduire l'
influence de l'uci l'union cycliste
internationale dans la lutte contre le
dopage
selon lui on peut en effet à la fois
faire la promotion et la police d'un
même sport en même temps alors sans plus
tarder retour ce matin sur à cette
audition bonne matinée à tous chaque
collègue gueule reprenons le cours de
nos auditions et nous avons le plaisir
et l'honneur de recevoir travesti régate
président de l'agencé américaine
antidopage usada
je signale nombreuses personnes qui nous
ont rejoints pour cette audition que
seul notre invité de ce matin
s'expriment et que vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de réagir positivement ou
négativement
pendant l'audition je vous le très
demandé et non pas vous imposer une
procédure qui est complètement
indispensable dans les commissions d
enquête devant le parlement français
c'est ce que nous appelons la prestation
de serment
je vais vous demander le style est bien
vouloir nous dire la vérité toute la
vérité sur ce que vous savez être levé
la main droite et dire je te jure elle
soins on s'est battu avec ses armes
égales
et là le déroulement classique de nos
audition devant cette commission
denquête consiste à laisser la personne
qui a accepté de venir à notre rencontre
s'exprimer pendant environ un quart
d'heure vingt minutes pour nous faire
part de ce qu'elle souhaite nous dire en
priorité sur la lutte contre le dopage
nous aurons ensuite un certain nombre de
questions à vous poser à commencer par
notre rapporteur jean jacques lozach qui
est à l'origine de la mise en place de
cette commission dans get avec notre
collègue malade michel et donc vous
donne la parole à dans un premier temps
et on vous écoute
vaincus monsieur le président je vous
remercie
mesdames et messieurs membre de la
commission je vous remercie infiniment
de m'avoir invité jean-paul travis
tygart je suis seuil haut de l'agencé
américaine antidopage usada
donc je ne pars pas français
malheureusement donc je suis vraiment
très heureux que vous est demandé que je
m'engage je suis le vérité et pas sûr
que le fait que je m'exprime en français
j'en serais incapable je représente lui
et sa dame nous avons à un personnel de
nombreux plutôt réduit mais très engagé
très professionnel et on travaille au
nom de et pour tous les athlètes qui ne
se dope pas aux états unis monsieur le
président je voudrais vous remercier
pour votre intérêt à ce sujet pour le
crime ce porte le sport sans dopage sont
substances illicites et de m'avoir donné
l'occasion de paraître devant vous je
suis père de trois enfants
et j'espère qu'un jour mes enfants vont
apprendre toutes ces leçons essentielles
que l'on tire de la participation aux
sports qui sont pratiqués avec intégrité
avec honneur et sans l'utilisation de
substances interdites
comme vous le savez dans sa forme la
plus pure le sport développe le
caractère fait la promotion de du
dévouement de la participation aux
équipes d'engagement pour une cause plus
grande que nous-mêmes que quelqu'un
arrive un jour non à participer au
niveau olympique ou niveau professionnel
ou non le vrai sport se base sur l'idée
de l'honnêteté du respect de l'équité
et des opportunités égales pour tout le
monde pour qu'ils puissent réussir et
cela dans un cadre des kits et
juridiques ce sont les mêmes principes
qui sont à la base de toute société
libre et démocratique
le dopage grignote réduit ses principes
et compromet tout ce qu'il ya de la
valeur dans le sport et c'est pour cela
que nous devons travailler sur la façon
dont on peut vraiment faire réaliser les
promesses que l'on fait aux athlètes
dans le monde entier à savoir qu'ils
peuvent participer dans un sport sans
dopage
comme vous le savez le stade a été
reconnu comme par l'autre par le congrès
américain comme étant l' agence
antidopage pour les jeux olympiques par
un clic et panaméricains nous n'aurons
pas de juridiction sur les cinq grands
sports professionnels qui ont lieu aux
états unis nous sommes en effet hainaut
sociation une organisation privée et
fiant à but non lucratif nous avons
conseil composé de dix membres
hélas pour eux ou dirigés pour survire
on est là pas là pour faire des enquêtes
ou pour surveiller les opérations au
jour le jour nous avons un budget annuel
de 14 millions de dollars et prend 8,5
millions de dollars américains une
proviennent du gouvernement fédéral et
le reste provient de sources privées y
compris notre propre comité olympique
national
il est essentiel pour toutes les agences
antidopage d'avoir une source de revenus
permanentes et de préférence provenant
de plusieurs sources pour être certain
que pas une seule source unique met en
danger la santé ou la capacité de
décision indépendante de l'organisation
dont j'ai compris que j'étais invité en
grande partie parce que nous avons
proposé une décision rescision
raisonner sur la fer de lance armstrong
il y a 6 mois a confirmé ce que de
nombreuses personnes avec ont fait le
penser depuis de nombreuses années à
savoir que c'est quand même le cyclisme
le peloton du cyclisme avait succombé au
dopage et qui avait une culture de
corruption dans le sport
nous avons découvert à travers nous
inquiète que c'était à la base de notre
décision et à travers nos enquêtes
actuellement coup on a découvert que
l'époque de l'épée au de transfusion
sanguine était c'était des pratiques
courantes dans le sport du cyclisme les
problèmes actuels dans le cyclisme sont
peut-être à la base des auditions
actuelle que vous menez je pense tout de
même que ça va bien au delà de ce sport
la corruption l'utilisation des produits
illicites dans le sport tout cela est
vraiment au coeur de la question du rôle
que le sport peut jouer dans l'avenir de
la société
on savait vu que pour lui c'est à nous
cherchons à la non seulement protéger
les athlètes et d'aujourd'hui
nous voulons qu'ils puissent participer
sans avoir recours dans ce qui est
licite mais nous cherchons également à
protéger la génération à venir de jeunes
athlètes le la crise qui a été décrite
dans la décision qui a été rendue ce
n'est pas simplement un problème d'image
publique pour quelques directeur de
l'uci ou même pour les sponsors du
cyclisme ou pour certains un athlète
c'est le trafic des drogues illicites la
possession illégale cela aussi c'est
interdit dans de très nombreux pays elle
cela représente un problème de
santé publique et un problème éthique
qui atteint nos valeurs et notre avenir
à savoir nos enfants ceux qui voudraient
utiliser des systèmes de dopage dont le
score ne sont pas limités par les
frontières nationales comme on a vu dans
notre décision certains nos athlètes
américains ont quitté le pays
certains ont quitté la france et se sont
installés dans des pays comme l'espagne
pour s'entraîner et pourtant des drogues
ils sont installés dans des pays où
selon eux il courait le moindre risque
d'être l'objet de contrôles inopinés
denquête en étant donné cela il est
essentiel que pour nous les agences
antidopage
on ne se limite pas non plus aux
frontières est et que l'on puisse
descellé des systèmes de dopage et de
corruption partout dans le monde on a un
partenariat nos collaborations avec un
field et le président et je suis
monsieur lane directeur de laboratoire
et pierre beaudry l'ancien directeur
c'était des partenaires essentiels pour
nous on travaille sur les sciences et
qui sont scientifiques de façon
scientifique de se doper et ce
partenariat est tout à fait essentielle
pour nous comme vous le savez au début
de notre enquête sur le cyclisme on
avait rencontré pierre beaudry ici à
paris ainsi que robert bertrand qui font
partie qui faisait partie de la fédé et
on s'est immédiatement rendu compte
qu'en partager les mêmes son objectif 1
et ce qui était très important
on avait le même courage pour chercher
et établir la vérité quelle que soit
cette vérité est très rapidement est
entré dans un accord de coopération et
finalement grâce à cette coopération ont
pu obtenir or les copies des résultats
des tests qui étaient publiés tout
d'abord abordé bien déçu par l'équipe
travaille journaliste à l'équipe et nous
avons l'obligation de travailler sur la
promotion de ce sport sans drogue et
n'a pas utilisé ces résultats pour
simplement faire la publicité nous quand
on a commencé en l'an 2000 on a dit
qu'on entre le combat contre le dopage
que devait être menée par identité une
organisation transparente indépendante
et il est tout à fait impossible un
autre sens de faire la promotion et de
surveiller votre propre sport de façon
efficace selon notre expérience il est
important que l'indépendance ne soit pas
simplement balayé que soient pas
simplement et fins de publicité pour
cacher des conflits fais-nous directeur
ne sont pas sous l'influencé de quelques
fédérations sportives que ce soit même
pas par le gouvernement et donc ils
n'ont pas de vide influencent ils
subissent pas d' influence politique ou
sportive des quelques sourires de même
que ce soit et tout notre personnel
professionnel respectent un code
déontologique très strictes qui nous
empêchent toutes et tous de travailler
pour toute autre organisation sportive
le comité olympique international que
l'on soit payé ou non et d'autres
restrictions loups sont imposés
également
de plus nous avons une politique de
secret professionnel donc nous ne nous
exprimons pas devant la presse à moins
que nous ayons une autorisation
spécifique et vous image et donc les
dégâts qui peuvent être provoquées par
exemple par le scandale
armstrong si des informations
confidentielles avait été transmise à la
presse ça met en danger tout inquiète
bien entendu mais ce qui est encore plus
dangereux c'est que les athlètes qui
doivent travailler dans un milieu propre
sans drogue sans dopage ne vont pas
parler et si le ps ont peur d'être
attaqués dans la presse parce que tout
simplement ils s'expriment et raconte la
vérité nous avons donc besoin
de protéger d'appuyer les athlètes qui
ne se dopent pas pour que ça soit loire
leur droit et qu'ils s'expriment
honnêtement nous n'avons pas non plus
d'influencé commercial nous n'avons
aucune obligation vis-à-vis de sponsors
par exemple et nous avons donc une
véritable indépendance qui nous donne la
liberté de prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour atteindre nos objectifs
sans s'inquiéter d'impact négatif sur
les intérêts financiers ou sur les
conséquences politiques pour un membre
quelconque de notre personnel et tout
ceci est très claire à la lumière des
actions de lucé y est tout ce que nous
aurions fait nous dans le scandale
armstrong à chaque pas lucile ou à et
chercher à se mettre en travers de notre
chemin pour cacher le véritable et n'ont
pas respecté leurs obligations de
supprimer le dopage et cherchons encore
à balayer cette affaire une affaire qui
a eu lieu sous la surveillance de l'ue
s'est dite tout à fait inacceptable que
lui c'est pour beaucoup avec cette notre
décision annonce son public je cite que
des mesures décisives était nécessaire
et puis par la suite qu'ils ne prennent
aucune mesure en novembre le président
de l'uci a déclaré dans la presse vous
trouverez cette déclaration ils sont 10
lorsqu ils ont établi une commission d'
enquête indépendante
ils ont dit que seule une un examen
décisif et transparent du passé vous
permettre de réagir aux critiques la fin
de citation or la seule mesure décisive
été prise quelques minutes semaines plus
tard quand lui cia démanteler cette
commission d' enquête indépendante quand
justement à ce moment là la commission a
commencé un véritable mener une enquête
indépendante a commencé se débarrasser
des limitations qui lui avaient été
imposées par l'ue s'est donc l'uci
joue un jeu d'attenté d'attentisme le
tour de france se passe six mois c'est
pas ce qu'on attend c'est de
l'attentisme ans on attend que la
tempête passe
mais pour les athlètes qui chérissent
les valeurs olympiques le moment de
vérité est venu on ne peut plus attendre
si on pense vraiment ce que l'on dit en
ce qui concerne valeur le fait ne pas se
doper de d'avoir des conditions
équitables us et y doit absolument
donner suite à ce qu'ils avaient dit il
faut qu'il prenne des mesures décisives
en il faut comme vous le servir la suite
à la publication de notre décision
raisonnée lui c'est accepter nos
conclusions mais avait fortement
critiqué le sada et la marque également
la chance mondiale antidopage et un
certain nombre d'athlètes qui s'étaient
présentés pour dire les biens et c est
bien le président avait certains avaient
appelé certains pardon avait dit que
certains des témoins étaient pires que
nulle et que il avait vraiment porter
atteinte aux sports alors soit ces
déclarations ne tiennent absolument pas
compte notre obligation de dire et de
respecter la vérité ou bien cela dit de
façon exprès pour cacher la vérité et
pour faire peur au témoin je ne sais pas
qu'elle a mérité la mecque quand un chef
quelqu'un qui est responsable du sport
s'attaque un témoin dans la presse
mondiale la message très fort qui ces
porcs est envoyé aux autres aussi ne
parlez pas votre sport ne cherche pas à
savoir la vérité et pense que le pouvoir
la vérité ne peut que nuire au sport
comme on l'a dit on en rencontre et l'on
sent ce trône en novembre 2012 et il
pensait enfin révéler toute la vérité et
ce n'a pas encore arrêté fait alors je
ne sais pas s'il va un jour révéler
toute la vérité je sais pas bien on peut
se poser la question de savoir si c'est
ce type her2
d'éclat en public enfin l'élite
l'explosion de réaction publique c'est
ce qui l'empêché de parler davantage ne
sais pas vous mais nous pensons nous
sommes convaincu qu' il détient des
preuves de l'implication de lucy lucy
dans cette affaire sordide le définit
comme vous le savez en dehors de la
transparence de l'indépendance dans
l'efficacité
d'après nous d'apprendre votre
expérience aux états unis nous pensons
que il faut absolument pour être
efficace à avoir des contrôles inopinés
rebondeur la saison sportive avec aussi
des tests longitudinale sur les urines
sur le sens il faut tester pour les p o
il reste 11 h et pour d'autres
substances qui ne sont pas sur la liste
habituelle tout cela doit être fait par
une agence dans l'indépendance qu'ils
font n'est pas sponsorisé par le sport
très clairement le sport afin que cette
activité est trop juste à être compliqué
pour des organisations nous avons pris
des faits des prises de sang des
échantillons d'urines c'est un travail
difficile
on nous a demandé de tester le tour de
californie doivent dans mes premières
années je pense que c'est un événement
cycliste le plus important aux états
unis les premières années on n'a pas
testé du tout pour l' ipo et comme vous
le savez partir de notre décision rendue
en devenir un l'uci avait des preuves
disons qu ils démontrant que armstrong
avait des échantillons de paix au
synthétique d'attentes son tour de
suisse
c'était des échantillons sur lequel il
est bon que le soupçon est non seulement
ces échantillons ne l'était pas transmis
au cours de notre enquête et on annonce
très souvent demandé qu'ils nous rendent
ces échantillons mais ils n'ont pas fait
non plus de tests des p o sur les autres
échantillons qui était apportée par
l'âme strong lors du tour de suisse
les programmes doivent également donner
une liste exhaustive des substances
interdites
il y a de nouveau me valent drogue qui
apparaît sur le marché il faut tenir
compte
il faut tenir compte des mers pratiques
juridiques sportive pure mesure de la
révolution ça à tenir compte de
sanctions aussi des protections de
procédures de protection pour ceux qui
sont accusés d'avoir enfreint les
règlements et il faut travailler sur
l'éducation pour modifier l'esprit pour
éduquer ceux qui sont tentés de tricher
il faut que les programmes à tiendanite
de l'investissement dans les recherches
scientifiques pour mieux tenir compte
pour mieux déceler de nouvelles
techniques de dopage et pour atteindre
de nous demander au niveau d'excellence
en termes de d'études scientifiques
il faut faire en sorte que non seulement
les athlètes qui sont accusés mais aussi
les pourvoyeurs ceux qui fabriquent les
drogues ceux qui se trouvent en dehors
des juridictions sportifs eux aussi et
doivent être tenus pour responsables de
ce qui se passe alors comme on a vu que
d'après notre enquête ne pas simplement
protéger les athlètes à travers les
tests qui sont menées car on l'a vu que
des athlètes des moyens très
sophistiqués pour éviter et pour tromper
les tests scientifiques n'oublie pas
hamilton floride lundi avait été
contrôlé positif
ne l'oubliez pas et finalement on a
porté plainte contre eux en
collaboration avec l'afld l2 avec l'aide
de laboratoire dans la sphère l'envié on
avait apporté les preuves de leurs deux
pages mais on l'envoie sans cela c'est
de particulier c'est deux individus ne
rêve jamais peut-être révéler ce qui se
passait dans le cyclisme
finalement on se bat pour l'âme du sport
et cela vraiment un effet direct sur
ceux qui ne se donne pas le moment
olympique
heureusement un groupe de tête très
puissant qui sans compte l'importance de
cette question et qui cherche
s'impliquer davantage
dans cette lutte on est appuyé par ses
athlètes car ils nous font confiance
pour appliquer les règles de façon
équitable à tous les athlètes y compris
ceux qui gagnent énormément d'argent
ceux qui sont des grandes vedettes et
ils veulent que les fans des scores en
pis une fois de plus croire à leur héros
nous cet olympique cherche aussi à se
distinguer de ceux qui trichent et est
malheureusement leur réputation est
souvent ternie par ces ruth par ses
combats les athlètes ainsi que les
sports eux-mêmes tout le monde en
souffre n'oubliez pas ne vous trompez
pas ce n'est pas simplement une affaire
l'armstrong ou de quelques athlètes mais
si tu touches une affaire de culture
générale et c'est pour cela qu'il est
essentiel d'un programme efficace en
place pour que les athlètes puissent
courir participé avec intégrité
aucun programme antidopage ce n'est
parfait mais d'après notre expérience
aux états unis tant qu un vrai processus
efficaces ne soit mise en oeuvre les
programmes ne serait jamais sopheak
expliqua ce qui ne devrait l'être mais
il faudrait tout de même avoir le
courage de se retrousser les manches et
de continuer à avancer et de faire le
travail dur et salle qui est nécessaire
pour le bien du sport et pour ceux qui
ont décidé de protéger ceux qui ne se
donne pas
pour terminer je voudrais remercier
cette commission pour votre temps pour
l'intérêt que vous portez à cette
question de déontologie de santé
publique et
je vous remercie d'avoir partagé avec
vous les expériences de lucette à
j'espère aussi que vous allez pouvoir
prendre des mesures décisives et
présenté à l'usada ses responsabilités
le mettre devant ses responsabilités car
les athlètes qui ne s'est donc pas dans
le monde attendent cela de vous et le
mérite
on espère que nous allons pouvoir
travailler avec l'alerté
et j'attends avec plaisir vos questions
mesdames et messieurs je vais dans un un
stand demandé aux rapporteurs
d'intervenir mais permettez moi de
commencer le questionnement en entrant
dans les détails
puis je vous demander combien de
contrôles annuels
vous effectuez vous combien ont lieu
hors compétition combien ont lieu en
compétition
sur quelles bases effectué rousset ces
contrôles est ce que c'est le hasard qui
vous conduit à tester puis ce sportif là
qu'un autre s des soupçons que vous
pouvez éprouver la vue de performance
quelque peu surprenant de tel ou tel
athlète est sur la base d'informations
appelons ça comme ça pour l'instant qui
vous sont données qui vous permettent de
dire on va faire un contrôle dont elle
sport sur tel athlète tel ou tel athlète
vaincu je vous remercie monsieur le
président pour cette question huit mille
tests lui les contrôles sont faits
propres parents notre objectif est d'en
faire 65% de ses 8000 contrôle en dehors
de la saison de compétition donc des
contrôles inopinés en fait 70 % 70 % des
contrôles inopinés en dehors de la
saison de compétition tout ça est fait
sur une base stratégique
on fait une erreur et un jus station du
sport au risque risque moyen un risque
faible ont fait d'une catégorie ont créé
des catégories de sports et donc on
surveille les athlètes et on regarde un
certain nombre de facteurs y compris
leurs performances
le fait qu'ils quittent le sport les
blessures qu'ils subissent
ce sont des éléments logiques tout à
fait logique que nous qui voulons
protéger les athlètes qui ne se tape pas
se sont amusés facteurs qui nous
permettent de diriger à bonne escient
nos ressources limitées pour être tout à
fait efficaces dans nos contrôles
antidopage nous pouvons aussi recevoir
des informations à travers des sources
anonymes un e-mail par exemple où nous
avons ça
numéro de téléphone que l'on peut
appeler et là on encourage les
entraîneurs les athlètes qui veulent
défendre le sport sans dopage pour qui
justement s'exprimer de façon tout à
fait confidentiel
ils nous appellent sur cette ligne est
très souvent on reçoit des informations
qui nous permette de soi lancer des
contrôles ou bien on mène des recherches
ou d'autres types d' enquête car
malheureusement nous avons vu que les
contrôles aléatoires sont moins
efficaces que de profiter d'informations
le fait que l'on puisse à penser des
contrôles positifs n'ont analytique le
fait de pouvoir utiliser des
informations stratégiques
tout cela nous aide
en fait à bien diriger le contrôle merci
monsieur le président tout d'abord
monsieur le président nous voudrions
vous vous adresser toutes nos
félicitations pour l'indépendance pour
la détermination pour la ténacité dont
avait fait preuve dans cette enquête
concernant la sphère armstrong et pour
reprendre une expression ministériel
récente vous avez réussi à apporter la
preuve que le plus grand des champions
était le plus grand des tricheurs donc
merci pour votre contribution à la lutte
contre le dopage
je voudrais commencer par une question
sur le fonctionnement de l'usada
quels sont les les vos pouvoirs dans le
domaine de la prévention dans le domaine
des contrôles dans domaine des sanctions
est-ce que vous avez également une
responsabilité dans le domaine de la
recherche
et si oui et de vous en relation avec
des universités et je voudrais savoir
dans quel laboratoire les échantillons
qui sont prélevés par l'usada sont-ils
analysé sont-ils examiner
nagui production je vous remercie pour
votre question sur la question de la
prévention nous avons en fait une
stratégie en deux parties la première
partie consiste à garantir que les
grands athlètes qui font partie d'une
liste d'athlètes permanente si vous
voulez 3000 athlètes et nous avons 500
qui font partie d'un registre de
contrôle au niveau national on est nous
voulons toujours nous renseigner sur ce
qui est interdit
nous renseigner sur où se trouvent ces
drogues comment ces drogues interdites
peuvent être utilisés pour des moyens
thérapeutiques donc on essaie de trouver
les outils nécessaires pour mettre en
place en fait le programme qui existe
sous l'égide de l'ama nous avons
deuxièmement un programme qui cherche
vraiment à changer le comportement et le
point de vue des uns et des autres de se
faire en sorte que les athlètes prennent
la bonne décision en ce qui concerne la
participation leurs performances comme
ans et vivent ce qu'ils mangent pour que
ces personnes soient bonnes personnes et
nous savons que bon les statistiques aux
états unis sont très claires la
probabilité que des dix ans des millions
de jeunes participent à des sports bons
et qu'ils atteignent un niveau olympique
au niveau professionnel c'est mon point
très très petit par rapport à tous ceux
qui jouent un niveau amateur donc on
comprend tout à fait que ces personnes
vont faire autre chose dans leur vie
mais les leçons que l'on apprend quand
on est jeune jeunes athlètes ce sont des
leçons pour la vie et s'ils apprennent
de mauvaises leçons
eh bien ce n'est pas bien s'ils
apprennent que l'on peut tricher
et son problème si tout le monde triche
et si c'est bien pour le sport et bien
c'est bien pour la vie c'est bien dans
la vie entrepreneuriale dans la
politique et donc nous pensons qu'il est
absolument essentiel d'avoir une
influence positive sur ses forces si je
puis dire qui font que au bout du compte
les enfants puissent être amenés à
prendre de mauvaises décisions en ce qui
concerne recherche en donne à peu près
deux millions de dollars par an la
recherche nous avons monté un
partenariat avec les sports
professionnels aux états unis nous
travaillons avec la ligue de foot bal
avec le baseball et nous donnerons pas
trop à peu près deux millions de la
pensée par an on essaie de travailler
avec les universités mais nous avons
aussi une certaine latitude
il marche de manoeuvre pour se tourner
là où se trouve le plus d'innovations
donc on travaille avec des pme avec des
organisations qui veulent participer à
cette lutte contre le dopage c'est un
objectif très noble
à notre sens il faut travailler là
dessus en ce qui concerne les sanctions
nous n'avons pas de lois pénales que
l'on puisse mettre en oeuvre cela
n'existe pas aux états unis la situation
peut être indifférente en france je ne
sais pas nous avons des lois qui couvre
le trafic et la distribution de
certaines de ces substances de certaines
de ces drogues et donc le fait
d'utiliser une drogue illicite pour
participer pour tricher et bien cela n'a
rien d'illégal mais le fait de
distribuer de fournir ces drogues oui
c'est un délit pénal
notre organisation existe pour faire
appliquer les règlements sportifs et et
grâce à nos accords en privé avec les
athlètes ils sont d'accord à travers des
contrats privés de
pour mettre en place pour respecter en
fait le code hama et donc ils adoptent
et mettre en place vous et codes les
règles de l'agencé mondiale antidopage
et voilà c'était exactement ça que l'on
mette en oeuvre
quels sont les produits que vous
recherchez en général ou prioritairement
et quels sont les produits que vous
trouvez le plus
est-ce que vous avez également des
commentaires a exprimé sur la liste des
produits interdits
telle qu'elle a été fixée par l' agence
mondiale antidopage et qu'elle est
également votre point de vue sur les a
eus télé autorisation à usage
thérapeutique de ce type de substance
l'utilisation de drogues substances
illicites conçu sur mesure c'est un
sujet qui nous préoccupe toujours en
parle de substances basique l'été au les
hormones de croissance et il y a des
corticoïdes anabolisants bon ce qui est
encore plus intéressant c'est à travers
nos enquêtes sur le cyclisme nous avons
appris que en ce qui concerne le peloton
il n'était pas en train d'essayer de
nouvelles substances illicites car
justement il savait peur d'eux ils ne
savaient pas en fait quels étaient les
substances que nous on pouvait
identifier et vous verrez dans notre
décision on a parlé des contrôles
positifs qu'on avait identifiées et le
peloton était très très inquiet du fait
qu'on avait nous identifier ces
nouvelles formes des p o
car en fait nous on avait développé un
contrôle efficace contre cette nouvelle
forme d t au et à partir des jeux
olympiques de beijing
et puis sur le tour de france des
échantillons des prélèvements ont été
testés de nouveau et on a contrôlé
positif sur certains prennent aux
prélèvements et le peloton était
vraiment furieux que c'est règlement non
dits ont été violées en fait n'utilisez
pas des bio semblables utiliser les
drogues pour lesquels on sait faire des
recherches mais il faut les utiliser
d'une façon qui minimise le risque de se
faire contrôler positif et donc quand
les transfusions sanguines sont utilisés
avec micro visage dosage sur les p o
pour garantir que les niveaux les micro
doses tpe
qui ont été assimilées ont quitté le
système avant l'heure du contrôle
et bien voilà c'est ce qu'ils
cherchaient eux au niveau dieu pour
l'otan mais nous on donne de l'argent
pour toujours cherché aller plus loin
pour identifier c'est drôle que
interdite
il faut en fait des catégories
déclassification de substance et pas
simplement une liste exhaustive car vous
avez des produits qui sont faits sur
mesure on a vu un punk au de nombreux
athlètes sont partis pour recevoir le
thé hug qui avaient été fabriqués sur
mesure et en fait si cette substance
n'était pas ne figure pas sur la liste
de l'ama et bien cette substance pouvait
être utilisé et ça ouvre grande ouvert
la porte aux athlètes qui peuvent aller
chercher des chimistes ans qui vont dans
leur laboratoire et qui élabore des
substances qui se font financer pour
développer des anabolisants des
stéroïdes extrêmement puissant parce que
si les règles ne sont pas bien écrite et
si la liste n'est pas tout à fait
exhaustive
et bien c'est drogue que peuvent être
utilisés sans conséquences et nous
pensons que c'est vraiment une
autorisation très clair aux athlètes
d'aller utiliser ces substances
nous avons dit déjà en 2005 après
l'épisode bako qu'on avait peur qu'on
atteignez les frontières
des systèmes de dopage sophistiqué à sa
foi que les médecins et les mythes par
son médecin et les sportifs chercher à à
trouver des moyens
qobuz d'exploiter le processus de me
médical et par ce moyen données indice
aux athlètes des substances qui amélioré
nettement la performance des athlètes
un exemple c'était un médecin qui avait
cherché à justifier l'utilisation de
testostérone testostérone sur un athlète
mal
un homme qui avait 28 ans un grand
athlète
et puis il a appris énormément de quoi
est il a passé deux classements très bas
en termes de performance dans le pays et
il est devenu un des premiers athlètes
on a fait une enquête on a trouvé qui
prenaient du testostérone et que
l'objectif était lui permettre de jouer
de participer dans des sens au sport au
plus haut niveau et nous pensons donc
que ce n'est pas simplement la liste des
sports qui est un port des drogues qui
est importante mais aussi la façon dont
les contrôles sont mises en oeuvre et
l'ama le rôle de la main à ce titre est
absolument essentielle bio
madame michèle ouï dire madame danielle
michel bien est-ce que vous pensez que
les fédérations sont suffisamment
indépendante pour sanctionner leurs
propres athlètes
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
ajouter une sanction pénale à une
sanction sportive c'est pour le côté
finition mais pour le côté prévention
vous avez dit que vous travaillez sur
des programmes pour changer les
comportements
c'est tout ce que changer les
comportements c'est difficile est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
ce programme là
attends que nous croyons fermement qu'il
est extrêmement difficile sinon
impossible de faire à la - la promotion
et de faire la police la surveillance de
son sport le système actuel peut
fonctionner et peut-être efficace si les
sports qui font partie du programme amma
renoncent à un certain degré de contrôle
qui souhaiteraient avoir et vous pouvez
regarder les exemples différents entre
les wmf et son travail avec nous sur
l'épisode pacaud et toute la réussite
que nous avons pu obtenir à travers
cette affaire et cela vous le comparez
avec l'uci et son attitude vis-à-vis de
nous vis-à-vis du cycle il soin et ce
qu'ils font actuellement aujourd'hui et
donc je pense que étant donné les
structures actuelles je pense que les
choses peut fonctionner mais c'est
difficile
notamment quand le sport lui même ne
souhaite pas renoncé à son contrôle
pour des raisons géologiques il ne
souhaite pas renoncer un certain niveau
de contrôler votre question sur les
sanctions pénales
c'est une très bonne question je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient de solution
facile
cette une réponse second à double
tranchant en fait on a vu que le sport
peut découvrir ce type d'abus monstrueux
des règles il a fallu beaucoup de temps
mais on l'a fait aux états unis c'est un
facteur positif que l'on a vu on a vu
que des agences telles que les nôtres
peuvent y arriver et donc à quoi bon
avoir des sanctions pénales en plus des
règles de l'association sportive ou
sportives
alors est ce que on peut aller plus loin
ce qu'on doit aller plus loin c'est une
très bonne question
on n'a pas encore
décider de comment on devrait avant
d'avancer je pense que le sport on a vu
quand il est vraiment la détermination
de volonté le sport lui même a peut
régler ses propres à fermer on pourrait
peut-être avancer plus fasciné
facilement si on avait vraiment des
sanctions pénales à notre disposition
sinon ce qui concerne le comportement
des gens et bien c'est difficile nous
avons un petit budget vous savez que les
jeunes aujourd'hui ils lisent le message
aux etats unis nous avons à une
industrie de compléments alimentaires
par exemple qui vaut 28 milliards de
dollars vous voyez donc des jeunes qui
se promène sur les terrains de foot
autres qui avale un peu n'importe quoi
pour qu'il puisse courir plus rapidement
sauter plus haut et c'est vous voyez aux
états unis des athlètes très célèbre
très connu et bien tous les jeunes
veulent être sept personnages et fin
presque n'importe quoi pour y arriver
donc le message est difficile il faut qu
on se met en contact avec les parents
qu'on est un moyen de communication avec
les parents si on leur dit simplement
que et il doit faire une approche
équitable honnête et s'y perdent et bien
c'est difficile qui va être honnête et
perdre par la suite personne ne veut
faire cela donc ça c'est pas le produit
le bon message mais on peut leur dire
que si les règlements sont adéquats et
bien ils peuvent jouer en profiter et
gagner mais c'est très difficile pour
nous car nos ressources sont très
limités
souhaiteriez-vous par souci
d'indépendance que la manne ne soit plus
financé par le mouvement sportif dans
les fédérations internationales mais
exclusivement par les états at il dit je
pense que le partage de sources de
revenus cela convient tout dépendait
uniquement des états où il y aurait des
influences politiques et l'organisation
et du mal à prendre des décisions
je sais qu aux états unis et je lui ai
déjà dit nous avons différentes sources
de revenus et donc c'est le gouvernement
qui apporte 55 % de nos revenus en
france et nous avons vu dans la sphère
armstrong en a vu les liens pardon on a
vu jusqu'où irez les athlètes connus
peau qu'on ne puisse plus s'exprimer
sont allés au congrès pour mettre les
freins sur nos activités
leurs objectifs leur souhait était que
l'on se taise et il ya même des membres
du congrès qui ont introduit des projets
de loi pour qu'on n'arrête non travail
nous on était tout à fait engagé au
niveau de notre engagement juridique
mais on avait aussi aussi d'autres
sources de revenus qui nous permettait
de survivre aux cazouls congrès décidera
d'arrêter notre financement et je peux
vous dire qu'on a dépensé moins de 50000
dollars de l'argent du contribuable sur
l' enquête amstrong 58 dollars mais je
pense que le fait d'avoir plusieurs
sources de revenus apporte une
indépendance financière
ce qui est tout à fait bénéfique pour
les agences antidopages malheureusement
l'argent doivent venir de quelque part
et donc qu'il s'agisse d'un mélange de
sources privées et publiques et bien je
pense que cela peut fonctionner et cela
a justement fonctionné jusqu'ici aux
états unis dans la décision que vous
avez prise concernant lance armstrong
vous avez pris une sanction sans preuve
scientifique direct mais à partir d'une
multiplication de témoignages qui
allaient dans le même sens est ce qu'on
pensait que ce type de défi de décision
va devenir on doit devenir plus courante
pour ne pas dire la règle
je pense que c'est déjà courant et juste
pour vous apporter un peu de détails à
votre question on avait justement des
preuves scientifiques mais on n'avait
pas de résultat positif dans le sens
traditionnel avec un échantillon à bruce
p mais on avait re travailler des
prélèvements pris en 1999 en a fait les
les données de passeports longitudinale
de 2009 et 2010 qui démontrait que les
résultats étaient dus il y avait une
chance sur un million que les résultats
étaient dus à autre chose et donc à
bruce on a pu établir que il y avait
très peu de chances que l'on se tromper
on a comme seul 1 % de nos affaires
résolues 20% qui sont le résultat d'un
résultat adverse analytique et je pense
donc que c'était un point de vue très
puissant pour nous qui vraiment faisait
la preuve de cette conspiration de
dopage
ce sont des affaires ce type d'affaires
représente à peu près 20% de ce que de
vous faire sur lesquels on travaille et
si on regarde le code hama la plupart
des délits sont basés sont fondés sur
autre chose qu'un résultat positif
adverse analytique et donc quand le code
à main est entré en vigueur les affaires
de possession de trafic de distribution
d'utilisation un lien tout cela peut
être démontrée uniquement par autre
chose que ou en collaboration avec un
résultat positif analytique adverse
quelle est en moyenne le quantum des
sanctions prises à pain lui saddam et
existe-t-il au sein de l'usada une
commission spécifique pour prendre les
sanctions sur la base des preuves que
l'agent savez nous règles sont tout à
fait conformes au code hama donc pour un
premier délit pour l'utilisation d'une
substance illicite
on peut imposer une sanction de quatre
ans d'interdiction de quatre ans il ya
des circonstances aggravée on peut
lancer un avertissement privé/public
pardon si on parle d'une substance qui
est interdite
en ce qui concerne la distribution le
trafic cette un minimum de 4 ans allant
jusqu'à une interdiction à vie est là
comment on fait notre choix est bien
c'est basé sur le nombre de fois que la
personne a distribué à utiliser ce tron
a été interdit à vie
les médecins également ont été interdits
à vie car justement ils sont empreints
de façon à graver leurs règlements donc
des différents types de drogues de
substance inhibe différentes formes de
trafic de cacher la sphère de très
nombreuses fois distribution armstrong
dont le lien donné l'occasion de faire
partie de la solution et il a aurait pu
éviter peut-être enfin on aurait pu
réduire l'interdiction à vie mais enfin
il n'a pas fait
nous lançons un avertissement
la sete qui est accusée accusés on lui
donne un avertissement de tous qu'ils
encourent par la suite nous avons une
commission indépendante de qui revoit le
processus sont des personnes que l'on
nomme qui passe en revue la faire se
sont pas ces personnes là qui prennent
la décision finale
ils font une recommandation et ce n'est
pas forcément une recommandation au
niveau des cinq sio sanctions mais
simplement pour dire si oui ou non ils
suffisamment de preuves pour continuer
le processus et par la suite sur la base
de leurs recommandations on décide si on
veut poursuivre la personne en question
est là sont précises les sanctions que
l'on va demander et donc dans le cas
d'armstrong
on veut envoyer lettre disant on va
demander une interdiction à vie contre
vous à ce moment là l'athlète feu
accepté les accusations qui sont portées
contre lui hooper demandé que l'audition
le son n'est pas lieu ou bien il peut
contester la l'accusation et la sanction
il peut contester les accusations elle
même où ils pas qu'ils ont accepté le
délire réfuté les accusations et tout
cela
tout cela est mais devant une cour
d'arbitrage un panel d'arbitrage qui
finalement on va prendre les décisions
pertinentes
armstrong lui et il a utilisé tous ses
droits de ne pas contester les sanctions
qu on lui avait soumis par écrit en
expliquant que s'il ne contestait pas
ces sanctions et bien il allait subir
ces sanctions à savoir l'interdiction à
vie
n'est ce pas dû au fait que dans la
procédure américaine
la notion de parjure joue un rôle
dissuasif évident c'est du moins mon
point de vue at inc
inoki élaboré nous pensons tout ça est
étayée par l'épreuve il avait déjà menti
sous serment
concernant le dopage et cela nous a
donné un argument basée sur la fraude et
le fait que cacher la vérité et donc aux
états unis selon notre loi on a déjà eu
d'autres affaires semblables mais quand
armstrong puisqu'il avait menti sous
serment
ça m'était beaucoup de pression sera
extrême ne pouvait pas se présenter
devant nous
sous serment et mentir une deuxième fois
et il était quasiment obligé de dire
toute la vérité mais ce qui est encore
plus important c'est qu'il avait fait
ses calculs il s'était dit que si au
moment où il refusait de se présenter
devant nous est de dire les vérités i
s'est dit qu'il pourrait dire ce qu'il
avait annoncé à savoir de nous mettre en
situation de faillite et de ne faire
chuter de faire tomber notre
organisation il est allé au capitole il
s'est tourné vers les médias
il a fait tout ce qui était à sa portée
pour nous démolir et n'a pas marché donc
quelles étaient les options qui lui
restait et bien de se présenter comme
martyr d'une procédure qui ait été
déformé et malhonnête et dans une
certaine mesure cela peut fonctionner et
ceux d'entre nous qui connaissent le
sport en connaissez de vérité mais
c'était seulement à travers nos
procédures et quand on a rendu notre
décision avec toutes les preuves qui ont
apporté avec les archives
aussi avec les résultats des
prélèvements avec les témoignages des
témoins oculaires 26 témoins oculaires
qui étaient là qui se sont présentés qui
ont dit la vérité là il s'est rendu
compte que sa première décision de ne
pas venir nous voir quand on lui avait
donné cette opportunité au moins de
choix et là il a compris qu'ils
s'étaient trompés
je vais président je souhaite vous
interroger sur lui c'est i dans votre
décision
outre les rapports de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage et les rapports de l'agencé
française de lutte contre le dopage
est-ce que vous disposer d'éléments
concrets important la démonstration que
armstrong a bénéficié de protections du
côté de lui ses à côtés donc de ceux qui
figurent dans votre décision
eh bien il ya tout un faisceau de télé
mans dans notre décision qui suscite des
interrogations
et on a justement une enquête qui est
encore en cours et bien entendu je ne
peux pas en parler devant vous
aujourd'hui mais regardez quelques faits
quelques éléments que nous avons publiés
tout d'abord si on regarde les
prélèvements prise en 2001 sur le tour
de suisse lui seuil est maintenant
reconnu le fait qu'ils savaient cacher
ou n'ont pas fourni où il n'était pas au
courant de plusieurs prélèvements qui
leur avait été signalée par le
laboratoire comme étant suspicieux qui
éventuellement qu'emporter de l'épée en
2002 aussi un prélèvement suspicieux du
dauphiné là aussi des soupçons sur les p
o et on savait qu'en 1999 il avait six
prélèvements prise au tour de france qui
avait été contrôlé positif selon les
techniques de l'époque et là ils n'ont
pas réagi non plus ils savent
on savait à l'époque où armstrong
travaillé avec mc et les ferrari qui
était un médecin qui avait été convaincu
de dopage de fraude d'avoir fourni de
l'epo aux athlètes en inde en italie et
oui d'accord cette décision a été
renversée pour des raisons de procédure
mais lui sait y avaient accès au dossier
il aurait pu regarder ce que ferrari
faisait à l'époque et on savait tous on
savait qu'il avait des relations avec
armstrong et ils ont accepté deux sa
part des paiements en liquide en cash
ils ont dit à l'époque il était au
courant des résultats où il y avait un
doute sur les faits n'ont pas donné
suite
aucun de ces facteurs quand on les
reçoit de 1999 100 sorties n'ont rien
fait à la place et ils ont créé une -
commission indépendante
qui n'a pas cherché à savoir quoi que ce
soit qui a simplement répondu à quelques
questions et qui a blanchi tout à faire
ensuite et ont permis de participer ce
qui violait ses propres règles de non
participation à une compétition pendant
six mois après ils n'ont pas envoyé les
prélèvements de sang un panel d'experts
c'était les mêmes prélèvements qui
voulaient pas nous donner qu on la finit
finalement obtenu à travers la main et
nous prélèvements enfin nos tests
experts ont démontré qu'ils avaient une
chance sur un million que ces résultats
étaient dus à autre chose en dehors du
dopage alors très clairement ils ont
fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu pour mettre
des obstacles dans un autre sur notre
chemin pour empêcher notre enquête
ils ont refusé de nous transmettre des
résultats de contrôles ils refusent
encore de le faire il y à des
prélèvements prix sur trois coureurs qui
faisait partie de l'équipe d'armstrong
ils veulent pas nous les transmettre si
vous regardez aussi le rapport qui a été
fait en 2010 et c'est un record qui
fortement critiqué les techniques de
prélèvement de l'uci et pendant le tour
de france et est immédiatement après les
données concernant le passeport de
l'athlète ont été publiés ces
informations ne sont même pas transmises
aux associations sportives nationales
mais tout ça a été donnée aux athlètes
et aux équipes discuter avec les équipes
avec les coureurs
c'est ils vont dire que c'est pour
qu'ils puissent être au courant de leurs
valeurs pour qu'ils puissent ils ont
manipulé par la suite si vous regardez
le timing le moment des prélèvements
trop de prédictibilité le fait que
mais certains coureurs sur lequel il
peser des soupçons et bien ils n'ont pas
été contrôlés du tout ou très très peu
il avait trois coureurs où il pesé sur
lesquels il faisait beaucoup de soupçons
qui n'ont pas testé une seule fois ces
trois coureurs pendant le tour de france
de domi 17 30 % des prélèvements dans le
tour de france en 2010 n'était pas
contrôlée pour les p o le tour de canal
du pardon le tour de californie est
contre on a été fait sur les p o il s'en
fait que quelques analyses cherchant le
testostérone sur quelques prélèvements
pesant 10 a été testée pour cette
substance substances connues mais ils
n'ont fait que 25 prélèvements pour
trouver le testostérone pendant ce tour
de france est la conclusion de ce
rapport de lio c'est que lui c'est i
doit mettre en place une stratégie de
prélèvements de contrôle qui doit être
radicalement différent c'était en 2010
et donc si vous regardez toutes les
questions qui sont soulevées par notre
décision que nous avons publiées et
aussi par le rapport
lio tout ça fait que nous qui aimons le
cyclisme et qui aimons aussi le sport en
général nous devons faire pression sur
l'uci pour que justement il prend des
mesures décisives pour répondre à ces
critiques et tout ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est de démanteler la commission
indépendante qu'ils avaient créée dès
que cette commission justement commencé
à exercer un tout petit peu
d'indépendance
vous pensez que c'est y est encore temps
encore crédible et qu'elle peut
continuer à exercer une autorité sur le
tour de france
est ce que vous pensez également que pat
mcquaid devrait devrait démissionner et
puis nous allons recevoir nous allons
auditionner le président de l'uci
bientôt est ce que vous auriez une deux
questions à lui poser est ce que vous
créez procédures juridiques et qui me
permettrait d'être là lors de l'audition
de patrick walsh et beaucoup de
questions à lui poser et sous serment
ont bien entendu ce n'est pas moi wa
lusala de dire qui devrait diriger telle
ou telle organisation notre rôle est de
défendre les athlètes qui ne se doutent
pas qu'ils travaillent pour l'intégrité
du sport une dépense encore les leaders
de ce sport en particulier a failli à
ses obligations d'avoir un sport sans
dopage
et lorsqu'on 2012 quand ils ont accepté
notre décision
ils ont reconnu et je cite leur
déclaration de presse ils ont dit qu'il
fallait prendre des mesures décisives je
peux vous apporter les articles de
presse et ils ont dit qu'il devait
prendre des mesures décisives et depuis
six mois ils ne font rien du tout et
comme je l'aï dit la seule chose qu'il
ait faite c'est de démanteler la
commission indépendante qui savait créer
parce que finalement la commission
décidé de se libérer
et de faire quelque chose et d'agir de
façon indépendante
donc si vous avez les moyens d'empêcher
que lucilly contrô le
les prélèvements dépistage et contrôles
sur le tour de france est bien allez-y
moi je ne le permettrai pas de le faire
nous le lui c'est à l'est l'autorité de
mener à bien ces dépistages et le
système a beaucoup de défaillances et
aucune agence antidopage ont crédible
l'us attin agences françaises elle
n'aurait jamais permis à de telles
défaillances de se produire ce sont ces
lacunes a qui font que les athlètes
malhonnête peuvent continuer sans être
perturbés dans leur façon malhonnête
question mais tout est lié à l'étude qui
est la nôtre en ce moment et puis je
vous demander quelles sont les relations
avec le département de la justice
américain avec les forces de police
l'échangé d'informations et ils courent
entre le sable et les forces de police
par exemple vous voyez que tout soit
curieux
vous pouvez nous répond ça nous fera
très plaisir ce sera utile oui alors on
est tout à fait séparés 1 organisation
distincte de ces organisations que vous
avez mentionné monsieur président mais
si on voit des preuves de délit fédéral
qu'un délit quelconque et que les
personnes que l'on représente à se voir
les athlètes qui ne se dopent pas sont
lésés et bien on présente c'est preuve
devant le bureau devant l'organisation
pertinente nous on se met à la place des
victimes on est là pour aider pour
représenter les victimes ceux qui
souffrent de distribution de ces drogues
illicites et donc à tout moment on est
là pour essayer d'influencer ce qui se
passe et de dd ou prêter notre voie aux
différentes organisations de justice aux
états unis qui l ont compétence pour
enquêter alors cette somme en sens
unique en fait parce que la loi
américaine travaille en collaboration
avec le code hama et l'unesco
des informations peuvent être partagées
en fait comme vous savez compris dans la
sphère armstrong
on savait que le gouvernement fédéral
avait mise au point enfin vie développé
tout un corpus de preuves sur le dopage
mais finalement on n'a jamais pu mettre
la main sur ces documents
malgré tous nos efforts et au bout du
compte on a réussi à interviewer le
nombre de témoins que j'ai cités tout à
l'heure et je pense que le gouvernement
fédéral a dû aussi auditionné un certain
nombre de témoins peut-être plus que
nous donc tout ça a été plutôt frustrant
mais nous avons su et également des
affaires opérationnelles qui est grande
parce qu est
ah les relations ont été extrêmement
efficace et dans le cadre juridique là
on a pu on a obtenu des documents qui
ont pu opter à pied nos enquêtes alors
c'est pas devant ce qu'on appelle la
nature et les grands jurait donc non là
on n'a pas droit de cité en quelque
sorte on n'a pas le droit de recevoir
des informations mais sinon nous avons
un bon niveau de collaboration de
partenariat dans la sphère amstrong ça a
été difficile mais dans d'autres
affaires les choses ont été plutôt
positif j'espère qu'à l'avenir on va
pouvoir continuer à collaborer avec ces
organisations
michel est ce que vous pensez que l'ama
et efficace et que feriez-vous pour
renforcer ses pouvoirs et plus
généralement comment la lutte contre le
dopage pourrait être amélioré
de façon générale je pense que oui aux
entités efficace à la madoff depuis dix
ans la lutte a été très dur mais
n'oubliez pas qu'avant 2004 lorsque le
code ham a été mise en place
s'ils s'étaient passé presque rien du
tout très peu de choses avaient été
faites par les différentes organisations
sportives pour empêcher l'infiltration
de ces cultures de substances illicites
et beaucoup d'argent des tentations
absolument immense
ce qui fait que les athlètes se justifie
dans leurs mauvaises décisions dans leur
utilisation de produits dopants et donc
je pense que l'ama a donné au monde
toute une série de règlement uniforme
qui donne une direction et des sanctions
qui peuvent être imposées dans le monde
entier vous savez une liste exhaustive
de produits dopants des partenariats
avec des organisations de la culture de
l'autre la police je pense qu'ils ont
été très efficaces
la faiblesse dans le système est le fait
qu ils doivent compter sur la qualité ou
la mauvaise qualité de certains
programmes et soyons honnêtes la fédé et
le standard se situe à un niveau et lit
double vlf ce trophée à un autre niveau
gmail mais vous avez pardon au même
niveau mais vous avez d'autres pays qui
sont très très loin du compte et tout
cela est vraiment frustrant pour les
athlètes
et c'est là notre problème que l'on
entend le plus souvent de la part des
athlètes ils sont très heureux de nous
dire où il se trouve longtemps le monde
de subir des contrôles les analyses et
ses saillies sont demandeurs c'est très
bien et il est vrai
dans une certaine mesure les procédures
sont intrusive
voilà je le sais il est très difficile
de respecter les obligations qui sont
imposées en termes de contrôle
antidopage mais ils vont le faire il le
faut pourvu que les gens qui trichent
autres respectent les mêmes normes et
les pays qui vivent dans ces pays
doivent bénéficier des programmes de
même niveau qu'à on suppose qu'ils
n'utilisent pas de prendre de produits
dopants et ils ont besoin de tes
protection qui sont apportées par le
code amont par exemple cantier questions
qui sont posées
il doit pouvoir se baser sur des normes
des programmes cohérents et cetera pour
lui malheureusement cela ne s'est pas
parce que souvent comme ça devrait se
passer
donc le problème quelque part c'est au
niveau des entités qui constituent la
main et ses entités ne sont pas toujours
à la hauteur je dirais cela pourtant oui
de deux dernières questions
tout d'abord je voudrais savoir si
l'usada va prendre une décision ou
envisagent de prendre une décision
concernant yoann brunel est il un
problème particulier qui se posent
problème de territorialité par exemple
et si oui il faudrait t'il que lui sait
y interviennent six mais l'interprète
l'interprète avait pas entendu la
première partie de la question c'est un
an chez pas l'interprète a pas entendu
le nom d' envisager de prendre une
décision concernant johan bruyneel
l'intérêt sportif et une dernière
question je veux savoir quel regard vous
jeter sur le dispositif antidopage
français et de manière plus précise
enfin c'est une question annexe
quelle quelle information
l'usada a transmises à l'aef est
déconcertant jeannie longo
pour ne pas revenir et vous poser une
dernière question après les dernières
questions
j'aimerais que vous on ajoute aux
questions mais sera porteur une question
sur fait que vous donnez nous vos
sentiments si vous estimez qu'une
procédure vérité réconciliation serait
aujourd'hui nécessaire dans le cyclisme
on a commencé par le cyclisme a fini par
cette question plutôt optimiste je ne
peux pas faire de commentaire spécifique
sur la sphère brawn et de façon générale
de désirs le souhaitent du sada et de
faire en sorte que toutes les affaires
en attente soit résolu dans les
meilleurs délais au bout du compte ce
sont les membres du juge de la cour
d'arbitrage qui rend des décisions sur
tout ce qui est procédure et c'est tout
ce qui constitue vouloir litige
nous espérons également qu'il y aura des
auditions publiques
si des auditions doivent avoir lieu des
auditions sur les mérites de la faire à
savoir si donc la tête ou si
l'entraîneur souhaite que cette affaire
se passe publiquement concernant le
système français je ne suis pas la
personne la mieux placée pour répondre à
ces questions car je ne connais pas à
fond votre système
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
avons bénéficié d'un niveau très élevé
de soutien à commencer par pierre
beaudry en j'ai parlé de notre accord de
coopération que nous avions établi et
pierre beaudry a fait beaucoup
secrétaire général est également robert
bos rang ensemble ils ont fait beaucoup
pour faciliter
dans notre travail au niveau de la
gendarmerie et au niveau d'autres
organisations de la justice dans la
sphère armstrong et l'aide que l'on a
reçu de la part de la france de ces
organisations c'est absolument
fantastique on ne pouvait pas demander
plus à on aimerait bien voir poil pierre
beaudry chez nous aux etats unis pour
que l'on puisse avoir accès justement
aux personnes bien placées
ce qui pourrait faciliter notre travail
et nous permettrait d'être beaucoup plus
efficace dans nos enquêtes à ce contenu
continuer avec prudence une fois j'ai
parlé des prélèvements de 1999 1 et les
lois ont changé ce qui ont permis de
partager directement les résultats ou
deux ces prélèvements magie et sa
constituer des preuves très puissante
concernant jeannie longo il faudrait que
je revienne ou dossier je sais que nous
avons fourni quelques informations que
l'on avait reçu à travers une enquête je
pense une enquête sur la distribution un
des p o
un centre de distribution des p o qui
aurait pu impliquer quelqu'un avec
jeannie longo avait une association mais
bon ça il faudrait que je revienne sur
le dossier pour vous donner une réponse
complète et précise sur ce point et si
ça fait partie de votre juridiction
et si vous avez une question précise je
peux vous apporter une réponse précise
pour terminer sur une note plus positive
nous espérons nous pensons que le
cyclisme pour la peine de d'être sauvé
sauvegarder et il faudrait donc donner
de l'espoir aux athlètes
nous penserons procédure process de
vérité et de réconciliation enfin bon
deux thèmes unités partielle ou complète
enfin bon quoi qu'il en soit les
coureurs devraient avoir l'occasion de
se présenter de parler de dire la vérité
c'est grâce à cela que nous avons pu
parler de ce problème d'exposer
l'ampleur du problème nous pensons que
c'est la seule façon de vraiment
s'attaquer à la racine du problème sont
simplement pénaliser les athlètes qui se
font attraper car sinon on va continuer
de la même façon pendant 15 ans encore
on a eu festina en 1998 et en a eu mais
le 180 6 h jusqu'en 2005
on vous pas avoir d'autre à faire et si
on met en place un processus bien
structurer efficacement on le pour
peut-être libérée ce sport de ce passé
qui est qui est sale qui est
répréhensible et donner de l'espoir aux
athlètes pour qu'ils éteignent justement
leur effectif et remplir répondre aux
espoirs de tout le monde
merci beaucoup parce que nous avons eu
l'occasion faire tourner sur le grill
vous avez répondu à tous avec une
amabilité vous honore merci beaucoup
pour vos réponses absorber
les membres de la commission présents
aujourd'hui garderont longtemps ont le
souvenir de cette audition pas qu'ils
gagnent
je remercie infiniment c'est un grand
plaisir pour moi merci
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sur l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage si vous souhaitez les
revoir ou en savoir plus sur ces travaux
notre site internet publicsenat.fr quant
à moi je vous retrouve cet après midi à
partir de 16h 30 pour la cmp la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi sur la sécurisation de l'emploi à
tout à l'heure ses heures 30